Speaker 1: Why don't we speak next to let's
speak to Rashad from.
Is that Staten Island?
Speaker 4: You know exactly what's going on.
All right, so, David, I I've been kind of
thinking about this recently.
I think it's a very I guess it's more of a
shower thought that I had OK, but I actually
think that Biden would have well, Bernie would
have done worse to Trump in the general election.
And that may or may not be a hot tea, you
know, but I don't think Bernie would have
won Georgia.
I don't think Bernie would have won Arizona.
And I just think Biden has more appeal with
the as much as people Dole, as much as the
left is on.
I don't like to realize it.
Most Democrats didn't actually vote, not just
tweet on Twitter.
Most Democrats actually vote for the more
moderate candidate.
And it's more interspersed throughout the
country.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, this is not whether
it's a hot topic or not.
This this almost verbatim.
That was my analysis during the Democratic
primary.
And for me, it's less about, you know, some
people some people speculate and I think it's
idle speculation that Bernie would have done
better than Biden in the general election.
My question has always been, what evidence
do you have of that?
I've not seen any.
The primary wasn't close.
And especially when you think about some of
the states you're talking about, I don't see
how Bernie would have done better than Biden.
If someone can explain it to me, I'm willing
to have my mind changed, but I've certainly
seen no evidence of that.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's just it just kind of
bugs me sometimes online.
Yeah, when I see, like, Leftest will blame,
like everything for it and see the the the
shadow that they'll blame everything else
except for the fact that people voted for
Biden over birth.
I mean, yeah, Berbee won in California, but,
you know, California wasn't exactly about
to go read and write.
Speaker 1: So yeah.
No, this is like my my analysis of this is
not based on what I would like the truth to
be.
It's just the Democratic electorate is not
well represented by what you see on Reddit
and Twitter.
And we learned that in the primary.
And I don't think there's anything controversial
about saying that.
I think if we don't recognize it, it certainly
won't change.
The first step is accepting what the reality
is.
Speaker 4: I totally agree with you.
Well, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Great to hear from you.
I appreciate the call.
Thanks to everybody who called in.
I'm out of time.
I am unable to take more calls today, but
there will be future days on which phone calls
are taken.
And I look forward to speaking to
you then.